the widow of Senator John McCain spoke
only to CBS this morning for her first
interview since her husband's death
Cindy McCain mostly sat out the recent
midterm elections she's gone back to
work with the McCain Institute
advocating for victims of human
trafficking I spoke with mrs. McCain
yesterday in Washington about life since
the Senators death and what she thinks
about the direction the Trump
administration is taking the country
it's been about 12 weeks since the
senator passed away how are you doing
I'm doing okay you know it's it for
anyone who's been through this you know
it's day-by-day but I remind myself of
the luck and the absolute wonder that I
had being his wife and being a part of
his life
he said you trying to carry out his
wishes in every way with the services
what was his message that he wanted
everybody to get well his message was
just that we need civility we need to go
back to a country that was lovingly
respected around the world
even in times of difficulty and
understood that when we gave our word we
meant it as you know a lot of people
sought and thought this was a rebuke to
the president did not know did you did
he even talk about that as it met it
might be seeing that way no no John
never spoke about anything like that
that was never not his intention and
anyone that says that is wrong but no it
had nothing to do with the present and
when Megan said the America of John
McCain has no need to be made great
again because America was always great
that was powerful line you applauded and
take our children honestly took this
very hard all of them did especially
Megan and Megan is certainly entitled to
and speaks her mind just like her father
did so and I respect her for that I had
not read her speech I did not know what
she was gonna say but I was very proud
of her
Senator McCain liked to keep a running
commentary about things when he was not
the direct participant did you hear him
occasionally cracking wise yeah cracking
wise and I think I think he probably
would have honestly would have said oh
my gosh this is taking too long I don't
think you know you know how he was he
was impatient I think that's what I
heard at times from him but I honestly
think he would have liked it did the
President or the first lady reach out to
you after the funeral no no they didn't
but that's okay that was not what I
needed at the time I needed my family
and I had them what is your feeling
about about the president oh gosh I
think I think he's questioning himself
right now as to where where he goes what
he's doing I think maybe the things that
have occurred especially with this
election maybe take him back to basics
I'm hoping it does I'm hoping that you
know it's very humbling to lose and and
if he I hope he learns from it and
realizes that
our country needs a strong leader not a
Negative Nancy if I can put it in such a
basic term we need a president we need a
White House that's strong we need a
White House that's not sparring with
each other and right now I think we're
things are in disarray and I would hope
through this if he does learn and what's
your personal feeling about the
president oh you know my personal
feeling is that he is now the president
of the United States
I respect the office and respect the the
you know you know what this means to the
country you know our families have had
their differences and and I'll leave it
at that
I mean we're we it's been said times
been hard for me to listen to him about
my husband
I'll be honest so interesting to hear
for the first time after her husband
passed a lot of grace there John oh yeah
yeah she has a lot of grace and he is
still very much there with her and she's
as she said taking a day day by day one
of the things she mentioned though was
that you know the senator died near his
birthday and now and he told her he said
on my next birthday when I'm not here I
want you to have a big party and I want
it to be a happy occasion so they're
already planning functions gonna do it
yeah they're gonna do it yeah remind me
again how long were they married almost
40 years yeah and you know I think it's
important so many people were wondering
how did she take the president's
personal attack to hear her address it
yeah yeah yeah and also that recognize
the differences of opinion in her own
family yeah I think it was interesting
he didn't reach out to her though after
and she said that's not what she needed